We might already know what the One Piece
is and where is it hidden, because i found
the X best theories about the big treasure Luffy
is trying to find in order to become pirate king.
Starting with a theory that has actually
already been confirmed, in case you don’t know,
the only person that has ever discovered the
one piece so far was the former pirate king gol
D roger on a island that is almost impossible to
reach and that most people don't even know about.
But if Roger discovered the One Piece first, who
put it there in the first place? There were tons
of theories about this, until Eiichiro Oda,
the author of One Piece, confirmed that the
legendary One Piece treasure was created
by a mysterious character called Joy Boy.
Joy Boy was a legendary character who lived
800 years ago who is still super mysterious,
but hugely important to the world of
One Piece. To find Joy Boy’s treasure,
the One Piece, Roger had to read these
ancient, nearly indecipherable artifacts
called Poneglyphs. If a pirate can find all
4 of the Red “Road” Poneglyphs, the road to
the final treasure will be unlocked.
After Roger found Joy Boy’s treasure,
he laughed uncontrollably, and the island that
held the treasure became known as “Laugh Tale”
So what is it?
Well this next theory says that **The
One Piece is the Devil Fruit Tree.**
The main power system in One
Piece are the devil fruits,
magical fruits that when eaten give a
person unbelievable powers. However,
we still don’t know where these
devil fruits come from. How are they
made? Where do they come from? Why is it that a
person who eats one is cursed to never swim again?
Someone who found such a treasure and
had access to tons and tons of super rare
devil fruits could form a supremely
powerful crew. If an evil pirate,
such as Luffy’s main rival, Blackbeard, were
to find the tree that grew every devil fruit,
his crew would become nearly unstoppable as
he spread chaos and war throughout the world.
We still have so many questions about
devil fruits, so maybe we’ll finally
get an answer at the end of the series.
Maybe Laugh Tale contains a giant tree
that grows the devil fruits. After all, the
devil fruits might not just be an awesome
power system - they might be tied into
all of the complex history of the whole
One Piece world. That would be crazy, but
a big theory that would be less crazy is…
that **The One Piece is Nothing**
Now, I know this sounds super anticlimactic -
but hear me out. Some fans think that when Luffy
finally reaches Laugh Tale, he’ll open a treasure
chest to reveal…nothing at all. If this were true,
fans the world over would descend upon
the Internet overflowing with pure rage.
However, people who predict that the One
Piece might be nothing at all have some
solid evidence to support their theory.
All the way back in the East Blue Saga,
on the Island of Rare Animals, the early members
of the crew met a character named Gaimon.
While almost every part of the East Blue
Saga serves to set up the larger story,
the Gaimon arc - which is really just
a single chapter - feels a bit out of
place. Everywhere else, we gain a crew
mate or meet an antagonist who still
plays a role in the story. However, Gaimon’s
chapter just seems like a random side quest.
Gaimon is a man with a large bushy
green afro who sought a treasure at
the top of a high cliff. However, after
falling during his climb to the top,
he landed and became permanently lodged inside
a treasure chest. After waiting for 20 years,
Luffy investigates the treasure at the top of the
cliff…only to find five empty treasure chests.
Given that Gaimon and Luffy have a lengthy
conversation in the chapter about the One
Piece treasure as a whole, could this be
foreshadowing for the end of the series as
a whole? Did Oda hide the answer to the One Piece
in plain sight all the way back in Chapter 22?
Gaimon’s real treasure wasn’t gold. It was
his hope. It was his dream. In the same way,
the pirates of the One Piece world have set to
the sea in pursuit of their dreams - a life of
adventure is a worthy endeavor regardless
of any tangible outcome in the end. Gaimon,
despite not becoming rich, became the
guardian and friend of the rare animals
on his island. But if there are clues
for that at the beginning of the story,
then something that seems more likely given the
HUGE reveals Oda’s been dropping lately is that…
**The**
****************************************************************One
Piece is the Ancient
Kingdom****************************************************************
On the other side of things, the One Piece
treasure may be the remains of the Ancient
Kingdom. We still don’t know a lot about the
Ancient Kingdom - we don’t even know its name,
but what we do know is that the Ancient Kingdom
was an advanced civilization
that lived over 800 years ago.
The organization that controls the One Piece
world known as the World Government originated
as 40 nations who came together to overthrow
the Ancient Kingdom. After the Ancient Kingdom
was destroyed, the World Government
erased the history of its existence.
They completely destroyed all traces of an
entire century called the “Void Century.”
However, if the One Piece ends up being the
remains of this ancient kingdom, then the whole
history will finally be revealed. The characters
will learn all there is to know about the Ancient
Kingdom, Joy Boy, and the Void Century. And it
will finally be revealed how the World Government
took power in the first place and what their true
ambitions are. This would set us up perfectly for
a final battle against the World Government. And
while that does seem like an awesome final battle,
maybe the treasure is something that more
lines up with the themes of the story. Such as…
**The** **One Piece is the
friends they made along the way**
The idea that One Piece is the adventure itself
or all the friends Luffy made along the way is
another big theory. This one is very similar to
the idea that the One Piece is “nothing” as well.
And while it would be disappointing,
this theory has some valid evidence,
too. The biggest evidence for this theory
comes from an arc called Sabaody Archipelago
when Silvers Rayleigh, the 1st mate
of the pirate king Gol D. Roger,
straight up offered to spoil the end of the story.
Rayleigh, who would later become Luffy’s mentor,
told the crew that he could tell them all
about the secrets of the One Piece. Usopp
was all too ready to hear the truth of the
great treasure, but Luffy quickly shut him up.
To Luffy, finding the treasure had no worth at
all if he took a shortcut. To him the thrill
of adventure, the journey itself, is just as
worthy as any physical treasure he could obtain.
After all, no matter what the One Piece is,
some fans will probably be disappointed in
the end result. But whatever lies at the
end of the Grand Line doesn’t erase how
much joy we’ve had as fans in getting to know
these characters and following their story.
However, there’s some good news for fans who
would be majorly disappointed if the One Piece
turned out to be nothing at all or adventure or
friendship. Eiichiro Oda has actually gone on
record stating that the One Piece is a physical
treasure. Fans asked him directly if the One
Piece would turn out to be the friends they made
along the way and he explicitly turned them down.
Instead of becoming pirate king by
the way, my personal journey to reach
1.000.000 subscribers this year seems
almost impossible and is only possible
with your help. So if you want to see
more of this type of content and want
to be a part of this crazy journey of
ours, all you have to his subscribe.
But if it’s not the friends we
made along the way, then maybe…
********************************************************The
One Piece is…One
Piece********************************************************
As in, the One Piece is the actual story we’re
reading. Okay, now this one is crazy. In fact,
my brain hurts a little just thinking
about it. But at the same time it’s one
of the coolest theories out there.
Now, we don’t necessarily mean that
Roger was just sitting on Laugh Tale reading
manga volumes. Maybe the epic tale that is the
One Piece story is written on the unbreakable
Poneglyphs that keep the historical record of
the Ancient Kingdom. After all it seems like
a “tale” or story that makes Roger “laugh.”
Roger comments on the treasure saying that
he wishes he could have lived in Joy Boy’s
time and that he was “too early” getting
to Laugh Tale for some mysterious reason.
There’s actually a big prophecy that says
Joy Boy will return - and all hints point
to Luffy being the reincarnation of
Joy Boy…whatever that exactly means.
One Piece is a hilarious manga so it would
definitely make Roger laugh. In addition,
the narrator often sounds like they’re telling the
story from some future point, so perhaps someone
will write the story or add to the story that’s
already there and leave it on Laugh Tale. The One
Piece treasure is likely something that can unite
the whole world, and nothing can bring people
together like a great story. So maybe the story
of Luffy’s adventures, either through prophecy or
through some weird time travel stuff, is the One
Piece. And speaking of weird time travel stuff…
********************************************************The
One Piece is Time
Travel********************************************************
We already know that a character named Toki ate
the Time-Time fruit. This allows
her to jump forward in time,
but not backwards. What if the One Piece is
something that *can* travel backwards in time?
This is a very crazy idea, but what if
Luffy isn’t a reincarnation of Joy Boy
at all. What if he time travels back to the Void
Century and he’s actually the original Joy Boy,
too? After all with the introduction of the
character Toki and her devil fruit ability,
time travel is now a real power in the story.
By going back and changing history, Luffy
could prevent all the suffering the World
Government caused throughout the
centuries instead of just making
things better for people in the present.
That’s why Roger laughed at his story. Why
he wished he could have met joy boy and
why he said that he was too early. Luffy
wasn’t born yet. But if that theory’s a bit
too crazy for you, here’s a more tame one:
****************************************************************************************************************
**The One Piece is just a bunch of treasure**
Now we come to what most pirates in the
One Piece world *think* the One Piece is:
a bunch of treasure. Gold, jewels, riches, and
valuables. You know, a stereotypical pirate horde.
And you can’t blame them for thinking this -
I mean, Roger has Gold in his name. His ship,
the “Oro” Jackson uses the
Spanish word for gold, “Oro.”
However, what the leagues of pirates who set
out to find his treasure fail to recognize
is that Roger isn’t your typical pirate - his
treasure is almost certainly not just monetary,
especially now that we have seen Roger’s
reaction to Laugh Tale and received many
hints about the Void Century, Joy Boy, and
the Ancient Kingdom. Much more likely is
that Roger’s “treasure” is something related
to the great mysteries of the One Piece world.
As disappointed as money-loving Nami will be if
she doesn’t find wealth beyond her imagination,
the fanbase certainly won’t be if it’s
something a lot deeper than that. And as
hyped as Oda gets about this final reveal, even
stating the series will end once it’s revealed,
it just makes us more excited
to reach the finale. For years,
the fanbase assumed that finding the One Piece
would then set off the final war. The author’s
recent comments would suggest, though, that
finding the One Piece actually will mark
the end of the series instead. Whatever it is,
Oda must imagine it will be quite the pay off.
**The One Piece is on the Moon**
Now we’re going to get into some wilder theories.
But the thing is: This is Oda we’re talking about.
Whatever the One Piece is is going to be wild. So
even though these ideas might seem out there at
first, they’re probably a lot *more* likely
than the theories we’ve already gone over.
Starting with: the One Piece is on
the Moon. I guess this is more about
“where” the One Piece is than “what”
the One Piece is, but hear me out.
There’s something going on with the Moon in One
Piece. The members of the mink race have powerful
Sulong transformations that depend on it. They
can only transform into this form during the
full moon. On the island of Ohara, there
was a Celestial Model with seven moons.
The Sun God Nika is pictured jumping
in front of it. Lunarians, like King,
are named after it given the “Luna” in their
name. And most of all, we’ve seen from Enel,
one of Luffy’s former enemies from SKypiea,
go to the moon. Enel’s cover story shows that
there are remains of a civilization on the moon
as well as space pirates and an army of robots.
Clearly the moon is going to play
a role in the story at some point,
so could it be that the reason Laugh
Tale is so elusive is because it’s
been in outer space the whole time?
On the moon, Enel found ruins that
seemed to depict the winged races of the One
Piece world as well as the ancient weapons.
If the Straw Hats end up there,
they could learn the full truth
of the Ancient Kingdom and the Void
Century from the remnants of the Lunar
Civilization - that truth itself could
very well be the One Piece. However,
there are some other crazy locations
where the One Piece could be located:
**********************************************One
Piece is in a
Whale**********************************************
Maybe one of the reasons it’s so hard for
pirates to find the One Piece is because it
doesn’t stay in one place. This theory states
that the treasure is actually inside the belly
of a giant whale. As mentioned earlier,
when the crew first entered the Grand Line,
the most dangerous sea in One Piece, their
ship was swallowed by the whale Laboon.
Inside, they weren’t digested
thankfully. Instead they found
themselves in a very pleasant environment,
as the Roger’s doctor Crocus had taken up
living inside Laboon so that he could more
easily treat Laboon’s medical problems.
What if the beginning of the Straw Hat crew’s
journey in the Grand Line is a mirror image of
the end? What if once again they have to
go into the belly of a whale in order to
find the One Piece treasure? But that’s not the
only place where the One Piece could be hiding:
**One Piece is beneath Enies Lobby**
During the Enies Lobby arc, the Straw
Hats take on the World Government at
their main judicial center. Enies Lobby
is a very peculiar island. It is always
day time there. And despite being
located in the middle of the ocean,
there is a massive hole in the middle of
the sea that Enies Lobby is built above.
What’s at the bottom of this hole? Where does it
go? Well, according to this theory it might just
be the One Piece itself. After all, what better
way could the World Government prevent people
from finding the treasure than building one of
their main bases right on top of it? After all,
only the Straw Hats are insane enough
to launch an all out assault against
this government island. But now let’s get
back to what the One Piece actually is:
**One Piece is Bink’s Sake**
This theory for the One Piece was
popularized by another YouTuber,
Artur, and it utilizes the fact that the lyrics
to Bink’s Sake seem to hold a lot of clues as
to the truth of the One Piece. Bink’s Sake
is a popular song among pirates that Brook,
the ship’s musician sings, when he’s first
recruited to the crew. The Bink’s Sake song
hints at the drums of liberation and the
coming of the Dawn - both ideas that keep
recurring throughout the story. So the song
also seems to be hinting at Joyboy’s return.
This theory also makes a guess at what
Luffy and Roger’s secret dream is. On Wano,
it’s revealed through Oden’s journal
and Ace’s conversations with Yamato,
that both pirates share a secret dream
that for now is hidden from the audience.
One popular guess for this dream is that Luffy’s
dream is to throw a party where everyone in the
world is invited. After all, after every arc,
he loves to celebrate with a huge party. He
thinks everyone should be able to eat and drink
as much as they want and make “merry” so to speak.
Luffy’s dream to become a pirate in the first
place was inspired by Shanks’s celebrations at the
aptly named…Party’s Bar - which would make this
reveal foreshadowed in a way from chapter one.
And what do you need to throw a
party for the whole world? Well,
you’re going to need a whole lot of sake.
Specifically, Bink’s Sake would be a jug of
sake big enough that all the world could party
together - coming together as “one piece.”
And when we think of how important the exchange
of sake cups between Ace, Sabo, and Luffy is,
this giant party would be like Luffy - or Joyboy
- exchanging sake cups and becoming like family
to everyone across the world’s oceans. And
speaking of joining the world’s oceans:
**One Piece is destroying the Red Line**
This theory says that One Piece isn’t an object:
it’s an action. Specifically, the One Piece refers
to joining the world’s oceans together into
“One Piece” by destroying the Red Line itself.
Currently the people of the world are
separated from each other and the only
way for them to travel elsewhere is to brave the
treacherous oceans. Not only would merging the
seas together make the oceans into “One Piece”,
it would bring the world’s people together too.
What’s the evidence for this being the One
Piece, though? Well, think back to the first
chapter after the Straw Hat crew entered the
Grand Line. When they met the whale Laboon,
what was he doing (other than eating their
ship)? Well, Laboon was repeatedly bashing
his head against the Red Line, leaving it
covered in scars, in an effort to reunite
with his long lost crewmates - who we later found
out to be the ship’s skeleton musician, Brook.
Our next clue comes from the Fishman Island Arc
- which is exactly one half of the Grand Line
away from Reverse Mountain. On Fishman
Island an accomplished fortune teller,
Madame Sharly, predicts that
Luffy will destroy Fishman Island.
The prediction doesn’t come true during the
arc, but she’s never missed a prediction yet,
so Luffy likely will cause the
destruction of Fishman Island
before the end of the series. It just
so happens that the Red Line and the
World Government capital of Mariejois are
situated directly above Fishman Island.
If he were to destroy Mariejois
and the entire Red Line,
it would collapse upon Fishman
Island destroying it. However,
by making use of the giant ship the Noah, the
Fishmen might be able to finally make their
home on the surface of the world instead
of being forced to live beneath the sea.
Destroying the Red Line would also help many of
the Straw Hats fulfill their ultimate
dreams. If the seas were all combined,
it would form the All Blue for Sanji. Brook
would be reunited with Laboon. Franky could
freely voyage around the world and Nami
could reach any sea to draw her maps.
And this theory in particular has a lot
of evidence speaking for it. It’s a crazy
story that involves Oars, Greek Mythology and
the true history of the one piece world. So I
really recommend you check that video
out right here. Thanks for watching.